nos dicen a continuación se muestra la
gráfica de la función h y su derivada h
prima vemos que la función h está en
color azul y su derivada h prima está en
color anaranjado a cuatro estudiantes se
les pide dar una justificación con base
en el cálculo tomando en cuenta que h se
incrementa cuando x es mayor que 0
puedes asociar los comentarios del
maestro con las justificaciones de los
estudiantes antes de ver que escribieron
los estudiantes podemos ver directamente
en la gráfica que h se incrementa cuando
x es mayor que 0 pero el observar
solamente la gráfica de h no es una
justificación con base en el cálculo
solo estamos usando nuestro conocimiento
de cómo luce una gráfica cuando se
incrementa para tener una justificación
con base en el cálculo
tenemos que usar cálculo quizá usar la
derivada de la función quizás recuerden
que cuando una función se incrementa su
derivada es positiva
así que sin ver qué es lo que dicen los
estudiantes vamos a ver qué es lo que
diría yo como justificación con base en
el cálculo y de hecho no tengo que ver
la gráfica de h solo necesito ver la
gráfica de h prima
h prima es positiva cuando x es mayor
que 0 si la derivada es positiva
entonces la pendiente de la línea
tangente es positiva que a su vez
significa que la gráfica original está
incrementando veamos
puedes asociar los comentarios del
maestro con las justificaciones de los
estudiantes
la primera justificación dice la
derivada de h se incrementa cuando x es
mayor que 0 vemos en la gráfica que es
cierto la derivada de h incrementa
cuando x es mayor que 0 pero esa no es
una justificación con base en el cálculo
por ejemplo la derivada podría
incrementarse aún siendo negativa en
cuyo caso h estaría disminuyendo la
justificación apropiada es que h prima
es positiva no que sea incremente ya que
podría estarse incrementando y aún así
no ser positiva yo creo que el
comentario que le corresponde es que no
justifica porque h se incrementa la
segunda justificación dice cuando x es
mayor que 0 mientras los valores de x se
incrementan los valores de la función
también se incrementan
una justificación del por qué h se
incrementa pero no es una justificación
con base en el cálculo el comentario que
le corresponde es no es una
justificación con base en el cálculo la
tercera justificación dice está arriba
del eje x a qué se refiere esto se trata
de h h prima si dijera que h prima está
arriba del eje x cuando x es mayor que 0
entonces sería una buena respuesta pero
solo dice esto está arriba del eje pero
no dice que es ni en qué intervalo así
que el comentario correcto sería por
favor usa un lenguaje más preciso esto
no es una justificación correcta
finalmente la última justificación dice
la derivada de h es positiva cuando x es
mayor que 0 en efecto es la
justificación correcta si la derivada es
positiva significa que la función
original se está incrementando en ese
valor así que el comentario correcto es
bien respuesta correcta y con esto
terminamos